dori mccullough lawson what is posterity
about posterity is a collection of
letters from great Americans to their
children and the letters go from 1664
all the way up to 1998 why did you do
this I did it because I am a reader of
biography and I whenever I'm reading
biography I love the parts about family
and I love the letters and I had read
collection of NC wives letters and
Theodore Roosevelt's letters and when I
had my own children it was a book that I
wanted to read I thought I wonder what
other great Americans have written to
their children and I wanted to read
those letters and I couldn't find it and
at first I wanted my father to do at the
book my father's David the historian
David McCullough and I thought that it
was a good book for him to do because I
wanted to read it and he loved the idea
but I realized after a while he wasn't
he thought is a terrific idea but he
wasn't going to do it so I went to work
on it myself how did you do it I first
began by compiling a big list of great
Americans hundreds of people and it's
amazing that then I started to look to
see who had children and who didn't and
it's amazing to see how many great
Americans didn't have children and that
cut the list down very quickly then I
began looking at those who did have
children whether there were collections
of letters that were available and just
kind of cut the list down and down and
down until I had approximately 3,000
letters that I read and then I chose my
favorites how long did it take you to do
it it took me three and a half years how
did you go about finding the letters
well there is something a reference book
a series of reference books called the
dictionary of American biography and all
notable Americans through history many
notable Americans through history are in
that reference book and at the end of
each entry it tells you where the
collection of their papers is held so it
was a question of tracking them down
libraries and archives and universities
then I also had contacts with some of
the families directly sometimes letters
were sent to me people heard about the
project and people would send me some
pieces and I did that that's how I did
it you reference a fella named Mike Hill
in the book yes Mike Hill is a is a
researcher and I hired Mike to help me
go he did a lot of the road work he was
out going around making copies of
letters and he would send me enormous
binders here are all the letters of John
Dewey of Chu his children here are all
the Laura Ingalls Wilder letters and he
did most of the travel how old are
Ingram's Nathaniel and Luke they are
seven four and nine months so what
letter in this book how many are there
month that's why I didn't I that's why I
didn't travel okay how many letters are
there roughly 100 ok what's the one
letter the one letter one letter that
you would want your kids to read that
might give them guidance Wow
well I think each child is different so
it may be a different letter for each
child but for my daughter
I think the W EBD boys letter to his
daughter is one of the most poignant
pieces in the book daughter - Oh Sarah
yeah no that's a Frederick Douglass this
oh that's right yeah I've got it
actually in Amanda yeah and it's a
letter telling her what he expects out
of her and also to have faith in herself
and that he expects her to be a
wonderful woman
it's a terrific letter and the letter
was written to her
where was she she was 14 years old and
she had just gone to England to go to a
boarding school there was a privilege
for her to attend since above all
remember dear that you have a great
opportunity you are in one of the
world's best schools in one of the
world's greatest modern empires millions
of boys and girls all over this world
would give home
anything that possess to be where you
are you are there by no desert or merit
of yours but only by lucky chance why
would he say that to her because of her
her family and that she was able to he
was able to provide her with this
opportunity but he does he goes on to
tell her what he expects her to do to
take herself in hand and do hard things
while she's there read for Discipline
work hard enjoy it and and he says to
that it's the you beneath the skin that
matters yeah because he says people will
wonder at your dear brown and sweet
crinkly hair and disdain distinguishing
her from a lot of the white kids
probably she was in school with fat how
old's your daughter she's seven have you
read her this have you read her any of
these by the way yes I have I've read
them quite a few of the letters they
love I Alexander Graham Bell's letter to
his daughters Alexander Graham Bell
wrote a letter to his daughters about a
trip he was on and he sends he'd seen a
stingray and he sends his daughters the
lips of the Stingray and the tail and he
sends them through the mail and he was a
wonderful educator of children and an
educator of the Deaf but in teaching
children he felt strongly that they
should learn by doing and here's this
example of him he wants his children to
see what a stingray looks like and he
puts it in the mail to also there's a
letter up to his daughter Marion Daisy
Bell when she was 21
yes get your book if you don't mind now
1 page 61 the reason why I want you to
help me read these jokes oh the corny
joke yeah what was the point of the joke
he was very busy crunching numbers so to
speak working on data that had to do
with genetics and the deaf and I think
that it really was a break from his work
and he loved corny jokes and he sat down
and took a break from his work and sent
her these these jokes and I included it
in the in the book because
they are so corny and to see this
incredible scientist and inventor that
he would spend the time to send this to
his daughter I thought was hysterical
you point out in the deck introducing
the letter that his wife Mabel was deaf
yes
and how bad was his hearing his eye his
hearing I'm not sure but she was she was
completely deaf and he was an educator
of the Deaf and his father all it was as
well let's alternate these jokes
I'll start yeah an Italian count the
other day introduced his American
heiress to a friend as his finance see a
very appropriate term by and by the
Queen of Holland's latest remark to her
husband is my crown on straight never
take a 1250 train for it is 10 to 1 if
you catch it why is a pretty girl like a
mirror because she is a good-looking
last he travels faster than coal because
you can easily catch cold why is a stick
of candy like a horse
the more you lick it the faster it goes
one more when a a girl faints why should
you always bring more than one doctor if
she is not brought to she will die corny
corny corny he also though goes on to
write a lot more in here he says I have
just sent a suicide note to mr. Kenan
for I doubt whether it he has in his
collection a more curious cause of
suicide and he's telling I guess stories
here yes he's telling stories and about
things that he's read and it's it's
really seems to be sort of a release for
him to sit down and write to her who in
your experience who wrote the most to
their children that you found wrote the
most or who wrote a lot well Theodore
Roosevelt wrote all the time to his
children Ansel Adams writes a lot to his
children frederick law olmsted over his
entire life it writes to his children in
such a wide range I mean there's some
very funny letters that he writes and
then also some of I think the most
touching letters in
the book toward the end of his life some
are mean some are very mean Jack
London's letters are shocking they're
just so so cruel
I actually had it open to that page on
ok to 181 uh first of all background and
who Jacqueline was Jack London was a
writer hidden his most famous short
story was a call of the wild it's a
short story that sold the most of any
short story was the page 181 anyone you
know when Mikhail Gorbachev was here for
book notes I was asking what he read and
he said he had in his library and had
read most of Jack London's work why
would that be any reason really yeah I
don't know why it would be for him but
it's his work is very adventurous and
manly and carries you right through he's
um but to his to his daughters he's he's
just so cruel and I think that these
letters are an example also often a
parent when they're in writing to their
child is writing to themselves I think
and in these letters I think that he
really he's addressed the letter to his
daughter and he's sending it to his
twelve-year-old daughter but I he's
really aiming the letters at his ex-wife
who he's not who he's had to find him
you say someone had shot his prize mayor
in the head he was losing crops at his
ranch his finances were in trouble he
was fatally ill with disease kidney
kidneys and during the summer a dream of
his lifetime literally went up in smoke
on his 1500 acre beauty ranch in
California London was rebuilding a grand
stonemason which on August the 22nd
burned to the ground why don't you start
off you know my reading that the first
letter there to Joan and you say she's
12 years old yeah and if you need those
glasses come under here we go thank you
Glenallen August 24th 1913 dear Joan I
feel too miserable to write this at my
desk I'm sitting up in bed to write it
first please remember that I am
your father I have fed you clothed you
and housed you and loved you since the
moment you first drew breath I have all
of a father's heart of love for you and
now we come to brass tacks what have you
done for me in all the days of your life
what do you feel for me and my mere
merely your meal ticket do you look upon
me merely as a creature of whim or fancy
or fantasy that compels him to care for
you and take care of you because he is a
fool who gives much and receives well
receives nothing please answer the
foregoing questions I want to know how I
stand with you you have your dreams of
Education I try to give you the best of
my wisdom you write me about the demands
of the UC in relation to selection of
high school courses I reply one by
telegram two by letter and I received no
word from you am i dirt under your feet
and my beneath your contempt in every
way save as a meal ticket do you love me
at all what do I mean to you let me
interrupt and ask you but how much
research sin would you have to do around
these letters and what the circumstances
were I would have to find out as much as
I could about what was happening and I
often would do that through in this case
I would do that through biographies and
other collections of letters Jack
London's letters have been edited very
well with notes telling you about what
what was happening to his life in his
life at that time but each one did
require quite a bit of digging some more
than others to find out what the story
was
did your father or mother write you
letters when you were growing up my
mother did you keeping it yes I've kept
them we now all talk on the phone all
the time so I don't have many recent
letters from her but no letters from my
father people ask me that all the time
but there really aren't any what were
the circumstances as your mother would
write you she would write just kind of
regular letters about what was going on
day today I mean you were not were you
because I would be in college or
probably through college and then it
stopped because the top we talked and
started talking on the telephone more
long-distance became much less expensive
so where did you go to
I went to Middlebury College in Vermont
very Vermont yes and when in your own
family did history become interesting to
you or biography oh I all my whole life
my father started writing history before
I was born his first book came out the
year before I was born so history was
just a part of life for us and at that
I'm the youngest of five children and at
the dinner table every night we would
all talk about our days and then we
would hear what was going on in the
building of the Brooklyn Bridge or what
was going on in Panama Canal that day in
Dad's work so I really have had it with
me all my life and what are the four
other children in the family my sister
Melissa is the oldest she's a mother of
three children my brother David is a
teacher he teaches English
I have a brother Billy who's a carpenter
and my brother Jeff is a lawyer and
you've been working with your dad for
how long for twelve years what do you do
for him I'm a lecture agent and I
started when dad's book Truman came out
I was I headed to medical school and the
book came out and he'd been working on
it for ten years and it was a kind of a
dream for all of us to have it hit the
way that it did and I decided I would
defer from medical school for a year and
help with what needed to be done and
during the course of that year I
realized that there was a business there
being a lecture agent and so I didn't go
to medical school and started started a
lecture agency and what did I do and
where do you live I live in Rockport
Maine and how many people do you
represent I represent about eight people
what kind of I do all writers and all
terrific speakers can you tell us
susharma sure I can I represent Michael
Beschloss and Frank McCourt Nathaniel
Philbrick Evan Thomas David schribman
and Richard Norton Smith and is a
representative what is someone like that
do I do everything from finding places
for peakers to speak to negotiating the
fees to determining what kinds
topics they'll talk about in their
speech and then we do all the
nitty-gritty logistics minute by minute
this is who's picking you up this is
where you're staying and then the
follow-up and you've done this for 12
years what has happened in 12 years what
have you noticed happening about
people's interest in hearing the live
speech oh I think it's increased and
it's it's it's because there are many
many more agencies like mine because the
demand is much more people love to hear
the real person they love to see them
they love to shake their hand there's
nothing like it so I think that it's
increased tremendously and is there any
way of giving us some idea of how large
the average audience is for some of the
speakers you send out there really there
isn't an average I mean sometimes a
event will be as small as 20 people some
this weekend we just were working on an
event where there were 24,000 it it goes
all over but maybe the average would
probably be somewhere in the 500 to 2500
range I would guess and for somebody who
speaks what would be the average number
of speeches they might give in a year
entirely depends on the person what's
the most the most of people I have
represented would be 70 speeches a year
and what would they you know would how
many of that would be say be college
audiences Oh a quarter maybe their
corporate audiences college audiences
celebrity speakers series subscriber
based series and then sometimes they'll
be an unusual event like a a real estate
developer that's built a new building
and they want to get prominent people
into the building just to see what it
looks like so they have a speaker come
and have a luncheon and everyone thinks
they're coming to see the speaker which
they are but they're also seeing this
terrific beautiful new building that's
been built I assume you don't want to
get into specifics but what is the most
that anybody would pay for a speaker and
in your group and what would be somewhat
with the lower range they might pay
speakers I represent
and this these are my speakers we all
know that the fees get astronomical
would be Oh between five thousand
dollars and fifty thousand but go back
to history on this if you ever looked at
the history of speaking and how many
people years and years ago did the same
thing of making money off of speech well
I haven't studied I haven't studied the
speaking industry's history but I do
know in the book one of my favorite
letters in the book is Elizabeth Cady
Stanton writing to her daughter and
she's on the road giving speeches she
gives two a day and it's it's a terrific
description of what her life on the road
was like and it's not that different I
don't think then life on the road for
speakers now the hard part is the travel
it's the getting there and it's the the
receptions and the dinners around that
surround the speech that's the part the
tires people out and drains them and in
the book Elizabeth Cady Stanton
letter describing her trip although much
more arduous it's the same feeling that
she has one of the things I noticed in
reading your letters is that how often a
reference to religion or God or Jesus
Christ or being a Christian in the
letters I counted over 30 of the letters
that you've got in here did you notice
that I did notice that and it just seems
to be it was not my intention I wasn't
looking for that but it was a big part
of the lives of people and there are
there quite a few here's another one
Alfred Mann number 47 who was he he was
a naval historian and he was the first
person who who really brought to the
attention of the country that in order
for us to be powerful we really had to
command the Seas this is a letter in
1890 he says he lectured his three
children on everything from medical
practices his page 47 thank you to which
authors were acceptable to read William
Shakespeare Walter Scott were approved
Mark Twain was not you have any idea why
he didn't want
read Mark Twain hide out in this letter
he writes to his daughter Helen who is
17 and it says I jump to the second
paragraph in the first place my dear
child you must not allow yourself to be
worried about this trait of your
character which renders you indifferent
to most persons as though it were a
fault or a sin for which you are
originally responsible do you have any
idea what that's all about well she was
having trouble attaching to people and
he it was a sentiment that he had felt
in himself that he often felt detached
from other people and it's a case of do
as I say not as I do he's telling her
she can do better than he has and that
she really that indifference is
something that she should shy away from
as much as possible she needs to feel
and she needs to be attached and
sometimes people find that de tat they
act like that detachment is is a
strength and he's telling her no it's
really a weakness and you've got to work
on it he later says like my like
yourself I am naturally indifferent to
others and for many years I thought it
was almost something to be proud of
uh-huh if you ever know anybody that's
totally indifferent to others yes I
think I have known some people
indifferent to other how do you how does
it manifest itself how do you see it
they just don't care about it we can
just see that their their level of
emotion their reaction to events in
their lives whether they're terrific or
terrible all sort of stay at about the
same same level same pace another one
that was somewhat nasty was Eugene
O'Neill yes who was he he was a
playwright he won the Pulitzer Prize
four times the Nobel Prize on page 58
pitch he had a number of letters of from
him in the book and I think I think
they're terrific I love to see the
writers particularly writing offstage to
see where they're not doing something
for publication and to
see how they ride to their children he
wrote to his son Eugene O'Neill was 19
at the time a letter was in 1930 and the
question is whether or not Eugene
O'Neill wants to bring his his
girlfriend to France where he is with
his third wife Carlotta right
what what's why did this let her get
your attention because I thought it was
such an unusual piece of advice you
often have parents who want their their
child to bring them in on their love
affairs if this is serious let me meet
this person let this person become a
part of our lives and here Eugene
O'Neill who really has not I did not
have much success with marriage and love
is telling his son if you want this to
work with this woman forget it don't
bring her near us or you'll have trouble
with your love or with your family or
both and he also is concerned that if
the son brings the girlfriend to visit
that he and the son might have some
troubles and he doesn't want to risk
that they have it's been a distant
relationship but it's been working very
well for some years and it seems that
Eugene O'Neill the father isn't willing
to risk that by having the girlfriend
come visit go to the next place on page
60 in that third line there read from
where it says keep your love affairs
free okay keep your love affairs free
from all relatives in their homes if you
want to avoid complications with your
love or with your relatives or both why
run the risk with your love of forcing
it into human interrelationships where
you never can foretell what the answer
may be for example how do you know Betty
would like me or Carla or Carlotta or
that we would like her you may say you
know but that is only because you feel
affection for all concerned
and if one dislike crept into this
combination then all the slumbering
prejudices would awake and the
complications would start and spread
later on he writes family contact a
trait as risk a one please understand me
right
Isis I respect your love for Betty and
she sounds like a brick to me and I
would sure like to meet
if I come to New York also understand
that Carlotta has nothing to do with
what I am writing and doesn't even know
I'm writing this I noticed it on several
occasions these writers would say things
like that the other person in their
lives knew nothing about what they were
saying their mother didn't or whatever
was right um and I think they're just
showing the confidentiality of the
letter and that this is really coming
from them they're not writing on behalf
of somebody else's wishes this letter is
interesting too because Eugene O'Neill
his first wife this boy's mother he felt
and it really was true that that the two
of them were together and they were torn
apart by their two families they may or
may not have lasted but he had
experienced that firsthand with the
boy's mother so what was your practice
when you were growing up with your boy
friends and your family did you keep him
included oh I kept him away until I got
a really good one I I really I did keep
them away and my my brothers would were
older and very very protective and would
answer the phone and if ever it was a
boy they would say are you an upstanding
young man and then no one would want to
come around my house I kept him oh where
did you meet your husband I met my
husband on a blind date
in Wyoming how many years ago eleven so
when did you introduce him to the family
well that was a kind of an old-fashioned
and unusual thing I was on a blind date
and my parents happened to be there too
we all met at the same time so I didn't
have to go through it and I could see
they liked him and I liked him and
worked out
is he a writer does he write letters
he's not he's a painter so do you do you
write letters I don't you don't at all I
don't I'm a product they never did I'm a
product of this time I write some
letters but I'm not I think we all write
letters but some people are letter
writers I'm not a letter writer you made
a decision not to include letters
written through email yes why I did
because I think that it's different it's
we all kind of sit and type emails
I don't think it's as thoughtful as as
letter-writing and it's I just think
they're two different mediums two
different things I really wanted this to
be a book of lighters Charles W Eliot to
Charles Eliot jr. page 76 he was Harvard
president for 40 years from 1869 and
1909 it is just one little thing in
there I want to ask you about his son
he's writing a slur to his son who's 26
years old and this is something else I
noticed come that came out in some of
these letters the ego he writes I wish
you were tough and strong like me yes he
does but I think at first when I first
read that letter that was what jumped
out at me and at the beginning of each
letter I pull at the beginning of each
entry in the book I pull a quote that I
feel is the most important piece in that
letter that I want to highlight and at
first the line that you mentioned about
tough and strong like me was the line
that I pulled because that's what jumped
out at me I thought wow this is
something but then I as I got to know
the letter more I realized that he does
wish that the son is tough and strong
like him yet he's so tolerant of the way
that the son is they're different people
and he respects that the son is
different and he suggests that the that
his son he says I can work all the time
but she'll probably only be able to work
five hours a day because just because of
the way you're made up but you might
have a much better life than I do and
then he says if you feel the Blues
coming on get a book and a glass of wine
and I thought that it was really a very
understanding and encouraging letter
after all when when it first had jumped
out at me as as an egotistical slam your
father writes the introduction the
forward to this book and he mentions and
I think you mentioning coming saying he
did yeah you did to Sherwood Anderson
yes who was Sherwood Anderson and why
did you both mention his letter and her
letters in the introduction Sherwood
Anderson was a writer and his most well
known book the
we all know is Winesburg Ohio and I
mentioned dad mentions him in his
foreword because he particularly liked
what he said about painting and about
work Sherwood Anderson writes to his son
who's studying painting and gives him
and Sherwood Anderson also painted too
so he knew about painting but he's
giving his son ideas about the way that
one should paint and that it should
really come from from your heart you
shouldn't be doing it too you shouldn't
be painting for the end result and you
should he says be humble smartness kills
everything he he's um he's telling his
son how to paint but really it's it's
about how to live that's the letter that
dad chooses the line that I pulled out
that I think is something that really
what the whole book is about is Sherwood
Anderson has a line in his letter and
it's it's in the middle of a lot of
things it's just one little phrase but
it jumped off the page at me he says my
heart is set on you and I think that
that's the essence of what this is no
matter what your relationship is with
your parents or with your child if
you're a good mother or father or a
wonderful month or a terrible mother or
father or a child that's troubled or a
successful child your heart is set on
that person in a way that it isn't on
anybody else and when he says my heart
is set on you I think that that's that's
what it is Sherwood Anderson also wrote
in one of the letters I am constantly
amazed at how little painters know about
painting writers about writing merchants
about business manufacturers about
manufacturing most men just drift there
is a kind of shrewdness many men have
that enables them to get money
it's the shrewdness of the Fox after the
chicken a low order of mentality often
goes with it what's he getting at he's
getting at that if you're a
businessperson just aiming at getting
money it doesn't mean much you're not
going to have the fulfillment that you
will if you love your work and
are working from the heart you said that
you were going to be a doctor at one
point did you really want to be a doctor
or was it easy to abandon that to do
what you're doing um I did want to be a
doctor but I didn't have and I wanted to
be a doctor enough to get to that point
that I was headed that way and going to
be in medical school but I wasn't I
didn't feel it in my gut that that's the
only thing I wanted to do that I knew
that that's what I wanted to do and I
had a lot of things I wanted to do and I
felt that it might not be the right
thing for me to do but it seemed it
seemed pretty safe and in a way an
easier thing for me to do because there
was a track I knew how to do it I think
at that age at twenty twenty-one that
track looked pretty appealing instead of
just what am I going to do do you think
he still might do it someday maybe I'm
still very interested in it um I may I
doubt it but I have illusions that I
what's the toughest thing about being an
agent for speakers oh the toughest thing
is there really isn't that much that's
tough because I love the people that I
work with so there's very little that's
tough the toughest thing probably is
middle of the winter a snowstorm comes
somebody's supposed to be on a flight
may or may not make it and you get the
phone call at 5:00 in the morning how
are we going to rearrange all this but
that's not very tough what's the worst
thing that happens on the other end when
you your authors arrive what's the worst
thing that happens for the event and
that the venue people that have hired
these folks to come in probably one of
the hard things that happens which is
just a matter of logistics is if ever
somebody is not in the place they say
they're going to be and someone arrives
and there's time lost because usually
it's quite orchestrated and tight so
that logistical kinds of things because
these people who are going to speak
they're professional they know what
they're doing but they get butterflies
and nerves and all of the in and outs of
cars and when is my flight all of that
needs to be
seamless so that they can concentrate on
what they need to do you're focusing
here on the written word and of the
eight speakers that you have that go out
how many of them speak from a written
text some of them have a written text
but they have it as I think something
just to have but they really go off most
of them just speak and how do you decide
you've got eight how do you decide what
kind of speakers you're going to
represent I assume you won't represent
anybody knocks on your door no I won't
they have to be a terrific speaker and I
have to respect their work very very
much and that that's really that's it
page 119 Woody Guthrie - Arlo Guthrie Oh
glad you're gonna and by the way I want
to ask you any time in this process
they're letters that you absolutely love
that you want - okay then - we'll just
do that
woody go through who wrote this land is
your land in your deck you say stricken
with a horrific disease in the nervous
system Woody Guthrie on a visit home
from the hospital once took his young
son Arlo out into the backyard alone and
what was he doing
then he took him into the back yard and
he wanted to be sure this land is your
land had become popular but he wanted to
be sure that his son knew what the
original intent of the song was and knew
the full verses because he realized that
his time of being coherent was limited
and he wanted the the lines they wanted
to be sure that our logo through new or
one bright sunny morning in the shadow
of the steeple by the relief office I
saw my people as they stood there hungry
I stood there wondering if this land was
made for you and me the timing on all
this was the date 1956 you say he Woody
Guthrie was 44 years old
Arlo Guthrie is 9 and he had
Huntington's disease Huntington's chorea
which is a horrific disease of the of
the nervous system hereditary you say he
had lived in poverty had troubles with
alcohol three times failed at marriage
and suffered the death of his
four-year-old daughter Kathy
and he writes what to his son our lease
says dairy are low Davi he this is a
letter that I wish that that everyone
could see it's written we'll show it on
the screen if you want to read it oh
yeah we'll put it on the screen it's a
it's a day I will read it it's a
difficult letter to read because there's
no punctuation and it's almost as I read
it I see it almost as a like a song I
mean it's it's a strange letter but he's
telling he's telling his son that not to
complain because human frailty is our
condition and don't complain about any
troubles you have everybody's everybody
has problems
dear Arlo Devi of course now concerning
you and that week early nearly blinded
eye of yours all that I are all that
anybody could tell you is for you just
to pray you're very head off for God
your heavenly father your maker and your
creator to heal you to heal you the same
as I do pray every minute here for God
to heal me of all my bad wrongs I've
done in my lifetime for God to heal me
of all my sicknesses I have here just as
bad as you have there god hits us all
God makes us all every living man and
woman among us all just every bit as bad
II sick as you are with your wee kitty
blinded I you're not the only one God
has knocked down sick with your weak e I
all of us when you come right down to it
all of us are just every bit as weakened
here in some way or the other maybe lots
lots blind e or sick or weakly ER than
you know living person is ever perfect
we are as weak leti sikit E as you are
so don't feel like you're the only sick
e one here on God's earth don't whine to
god don't even complain one little bit C
word back to God be silent be quiet be
thankful be faithful be grateful be
gaily full be joyful is that his way of
writing or speaking or will it mean it's
the way that most of his letters are
like this and I apparently and it seems
as his disease got worse they became
more like this and you do see the
handwriting that's jerky and jagged but
it's also the way that he was and
it's it's more of a it became almost a
caricature as this became more and more
with this faith he feel grateful joyful
did you ever in your letters did you
ever find letters back to the father or
mother and they said yes and you didn't
but you didn't include those I didn't
know I know because I had the problem
was there's so much material so it was
really a question always of of limiting
what the book was going to be there
there was so so much so if I got into
that it would be a different book so I
just I had certain rules from the
beginning and I stuck to them what were
some of the other rules I went through
and counted some 104 chapters but also
counted that in a number of cases you
had multiple letters NC Wyeth II had for
John Adams 3 and the Adams has played a
big role John Quincy had one Abigail had
two any impact from your father's John
Adams book because oh sure but also much
even more so their letters are just
amazing I mean I wanted some of my goals
in the book were that I wanted to I
wanted to see what these parents told
their children how they told them and
also what the letters told tell us about
the times in which they lived
so the Adams letters cover a lot of
those those sides but the rules that you
asked about the rules that I had they're
really very simple I had two rules the
the person the person who had written
the letter had to make a substantial and
worthwhile contribution to our country
and then the letter itself had to reveal
something of value
he said that Theodore Roosevelt wrote a
hundred and fifty thousand letters are
they all catalogs somewhere or do they
do they are the Theodore Roosevelt
Association as many of them the Library
of Congress has many of them they have
been edited so they're I mean they're
they're accessible that's amazing and
his letters to his children are just the
letters while he's in the White House
and his children are young are just
incredible to see this man who is the
President of the United States writing
very funny letters to little children
and then as his children get older they
become much more serious and there's a
letter in the book to his son Quentin
where he says Quentin is in the first
world war and his father Theodore
Roosevelt feels that he's not writing
enough letters to his girlfriend so he
sends Quentin the letter in which he
says right all the time right if you're
smashed up in the hospital right when
your work is most disheartening and exim
right all the time right enough to allow
half being lost and I just I think that
that's just terrific they all wrote and
it was part of part of life it was a way
of life and a way of working your
thoughts out on paper your your father
your father quote she was saying when
you got into this project think how much
I'm going to learn and what did you
learn besides what people said about to
their kids what else did you learn you
learn much well I found I found that
many of these great Americans were names
that I knew and people that I knew I
should know much more about than I did
and what surprised me was how through
the letters to the children some aspect
of their personality or the time in
which they lived or their experience
became immediately accessible something
about the unedited words their candor
made them so accessible I think
something else that I learned was the
importance of work and loving your work
and doing your work for the right
reasons again and again they say that to
their children your work is who you are
your work is part of you don't work for
the end result it's the process and you
see that coming from writers and artists
and soldiers and all across the board
that theme comes up again and again
where did you learn your work ethic from
my parents I guess and what would you
consider that to be and what kind of a
you work all the time how do you write
three kids and do all what you do I
don't there a lot of things I don't do
I really do three things I have
my family my business and while I was
working on the book I worked on the book
and I don't do much else we ate a lot of
spaghetti and butter and I didn't go to
too many parties how much time of day
would you spend on the book and I mean
how much time on your on your job well I
spent it depended on during the course
of the work that changed a little bit
but for the first two years I would work
in my office a full week and then I'd
work on the book after the children went
to bed for two and a half to three hours
and then I would work on the book on
Saturdays and then for the last year I
was able to take a couple of hours a day
during the regular office time and also
work on the book and it but I kept up
with the the evenings and weekends - is
there another book automatically because
all the ones you couldn't get into this
one not from me there's another book for
someone else
I started out because another person
would pick I think very different
letters there's so many and so many
wonderful letters that a different
person would would find different
poignancy and different letters but I
started out thinking that I would have a
pile of letters that were the first cut
and a pile of letters that were the
second cut and then at the end I
probably would go back to the second cut
and and include those some of those in
the book but none of them I didn't need
to there were there were plenty all from
the first cut you have a different
sections of the book and one of them is
called strength of character and you
lead it off with a letter from Jonathan
Edwards 1749 to Mary Edwards who was 15
at the time who was Jonathan Edwards
Jonathan Edwards was a theologian and
one of our prominent thinkers in New
England and he's writing to his daughter
who's far away from home and this is
this letter I chose for the book more to
give a sense of time and time and place
and he's telling his daughter that her
faith is the most important thing that
there is
I actually underlined and if the next
news we hear from of you should which I
found I thought this
part unusual but he says had it and if
the next news we hear of you should be
of your death though that would be very
melancholy yet if with all we should
hear of that which should give great
grounds to hope that you had died in the
Lord
how much more comfortable would this be
parent though we would should have no
opportunity to see you or take our leave
of you in your sickness parent then if
we should be with you all on your
sickness and have much opportunity to
attend you and converse and pray with
you and take an affectionate leave of
you and after all have reasoned to
apprehend that you died without God's
grace in favor just comfortable to have
the presence of earthly friends
especially in sickness and a kind of a
deathbed but the great thing is to have
God our friend and to be united to
Christ who can never die any more and
whom even death can't separate us from
but he's part of the Great Awakening and
he is his belief in his faith is the
most important thing to him and his
daughter is far away from him and he
wants to be sure she doesn't forget her
religious grounding while she's gone uh
John O'Hara yeah - Wylie O'Hara the year
1959 daughter was 14 and she's in her
first year at st. Timothy school our
he's in his first year at Saint
Timothy's she is she I'm sorry I in
Maryland the point of that letter the
point of that letter is to tell wiley
O'Hara that her childhood has ended she
is now going forward as an adult she's
reached the time of her life that she's
been looking forward to all along
growing up and that she has to do things
he tells her life is tough and you need
a little bit of toughening and in order
to become tougher you have to do it
yourself you have to do things you don't
want to do you have to make yourself be
with other people both he and she are
shy people so he tells her that I that
he is making himself go out and be with
other people and she needs to do the
same because the only real discipline is
self discipline did you find yourself
ever changing your mind about something
a letter that you read about how to
raise your kids or things that you
philosophy that you might I have I found
with my kids I guess that I would be I
hope to be very clear with them there's
so many letters here where parents set
forth exactly what their expectations
are and they let them know clearly what
they want I think that that's something
that I will do differently there are
many many times where the parent will
say take yourself in hand rule yourself
with an iron fist or John John O'Hara
make yourself do things you don't want
to do and I live in the woods in Maine
and one thing that I didn't really want
to do was come for me to come out with
this book when it came out so when the
time came for me to go on the road and
do some of the promoting of the book and
talking about the book I went back to
some of those letters and read them and
it said do things you don't want to do
do the right thing make yourself why
didn't you want to do it at this time
I just didn't I'm not a really a public
person I never have been it wasn't a lot
of times I think people are so excited
for the book to come out that they can
go out and talk about it and I was
thrilled that the book was out but I
wasn't wasn't on the promoting side of
it did you have to as a part of your
deal with the double-dated you have to
do so many book appearances I don't know
I had to do some I didn't get to that
point I just took myself in hand and
said okay you're gonna do it so how much
have you done I've done a few weeks
probably three weeks or so different
places not a lot and I've enjoyed it
that was I thought that I would once I
made myself do it that I would probably
enjoy talking about the foot can I do
what is it like or what maybe what's the
downside of working so close with your
own father as his agent speaking Oh a
downside I suppose the only downside is
that sometimes when I'm working with
other groups if they find out that I'm
his daughter they don't realize that I
have a bigger business and that they
think that I'm
just working with him that's really the
only downside as a as a daughter working
with a father it's terrific I love it
and I can I can tell him much more than
I can my other clients okay this is what
you need to do or make decisions this is
what time he'll leave this is he'll do
this or he won't and that saves a lot of
time what does he not like to do when
he's on to her he likes to do everything
that's the problem he likes to do uh he
really he'll do he loves to do
everything and then he gets tired out
from it or it takes too long and he's
frustrated afterwards but when he's out
he likes to do everything so it's really
limiting trying to limit what he'll do
before he gets there
now that you've had this experience
would you be interested all in writing
more yes kind of a book I would and I
really I was not interested people ask
me often if I always wanted to be a
writer because my father was a writer
and I work with writers and no I hadn't
I didn't want to be a writer it always
seemed so hard to me and dad would talk
about how he would pay to do what he
does and I would think oh that can't
really be true but I now see why I mean
I I would do hope to do another book and
it was really one of the most enjoyable
things I've done so what's the net what
would you do
I don't know I'm fishing around for
ideas at the moment and I have a few but
I'm not ready to to say yet did David
McCullough pick up the phone at any time
in this process and say Dorie you've got
to include this letter no never he
helped me with when I was compiling the
initial list
he helped me I often we talk on the
phone and I'd keep saying okay
try to give me more more people I
wouldn't think of and I spoke with a
number of people that way and he helped
me with the list of names but other than
that he really he really wasn't involved
much he gave me confidence in one
telephone conversation he gave me
confidence to know that if I didn't
think a letter was terrific don't
include it don't include someone because
you think they should be in clue
but if the letter isn't up to standards
your standards don't do it and that was
really probably one of the best pieces
of advice that gave me the confidence to
just keep going with my instinct if I
count it right George Herbert Walker
Bush his letter is the longest in the
book it probably is he had it in his own
book he did what drew you to this one
and it was when he was 74 years old
it's a letter about aging and I what
drew me to the letter was how candid he
is I think it's a it's a person I had
not seen before in George Bush it's very
long and that was one of the one of my
decisions too is that I wouldn't cut any
of the letters I wanted people to see
exactly how they were written and
intended and sometimes the parent will
repeat themselves or their a hammer on a
point too many times or they'll go on
too long and I think the George Bush
letter he goes on and on and on I don't
think that he went back and edited much
of that at all and I like that I think
it you see him you see who he is it's on
page 273 I'll start it off and you can
pick up a paragraph or two if you want
this letter is about aging he says it
was 74 at the time 1998 he just turned
80 not about the president's conference
on aging and how we should play lawn
bowling but gets get discounts at movies
turn into skin conscious sun blockers
take Metamucil and grow old gracefully
no it's about me about happen what
happened between last year and this
between being 73 and 74 it's interesting
well fairly interesting to you maybe
therapeutic to me for I know I'm getting
older now what would you like to include
in this letter
but let me just say here what happens
this year unlike last is I just tuned
out more because I do not want to know
when they are thinking of going to the
movies and I don't want to sign off and
having to take them all the way to
Portland so on purpose I either look
confused or simply proceed on my way
pretending to have heard nary a sound it
works then he goes on and he says last
year there was only a tiny sense of time
left of sand running through the glass
this year I must confess I'm more aware
of that no fear no apprehension just a
feeling like let's go there's so much to
do and there might not be a lot of time
left you kids keep me young even if I
don't bend as easily or run as fast or
here as well but I love that too the the
that he's acknowledging that he's aging
he's acknowledging that he can't do
things as well as he could but he is so
optimistic and eager to keep living and
keep going and not in a phony way says
if I shed tears easier now try not to
laugh at me because I'll lose more
saline and that makes me feel like a
[ __ ] and it might make my mouth dry
later on and might be bad for digestion
too and besides it's okay to cry if you
were a man a happy man me or a man faced
with sadness or hurt not me he said he's
having fun writing this letter too he's
really enjoying himself and that is
something that there are many letters in
the book where you can see that the fun
side of people and that they're having
having a ball riding a ladder now
Benjamin Rush who we just did on this
program a biography okay he has an
unusual letter where he lays out all
kinds of advice to John Rush I believe
it's his son that was went insane yes it
is and he wrote this in 1796 who was he
and he he was a doctor in Philadelphia
and he was a signer of the Declaration
of Independence and served in the
Revolutionary War
his son was studying to be a doctor and
it was during that time of his life that
this letter was
written the son later becomes insane
after he is in a duel with a friend and
he kills the friend and he's
institutionalized but this letter is
written before there were any signs
signs of the trouble ahead and I like
this letter because they it's from the
two parents from Benjamin and Julia rush
to his son before he goes off on his
apprenticeship in India and I like how
they just lay it out here's what you
here's what you need to be worried about
here's what you need to do and I love
the line be sober and vigilant remember
at all times that while you are seeing
the world the world will see you
whenever you are tempted to do an
improper thing fancy that you see your
father and mother kneeling before you
and imploring you with tears in their
eyes to refrain from yielding to the
temptation what a scene to imagine this
this young kid now you've got your
father writing it forward on here I
noticed another father-son connection
that Luke Janklow is your agent and Luke
jank Louis son - who - Mort Janklow who
is my father's agent and when I had the
idea for the book I asked dad and
decided that I was going to do it
I asked dad what I what should I do next
he said well I should take you in to
meet Mort and talk to my agent about
your idea so we went to New York and
went into Seymour and there was talk
that Mort son might be in on the meeting
- and I'm sure he had the same feeling
but I had a little bit of a hope or
rather the Son and the daughter and this
is too much and expecting no I'm not
going to like this guy and he came in
and immediately we just hit it off and
he's terrific and I'm thrilled he's my
agent and it was it was one of those
wonderful moments of the two fathers and
the two that fought the daughter and son
all together what's the difference in
the age of you to Luke Janklow in you
we're about the same age and I think our
fathers are about the same age this is
the cover of the book it's called
posterity
letters of great Americans to their
children Dorie McCullough Lawson our
guest thank you very much thank you